this is gonna take a really long time  i'm gonna move as fast as i can almost  immediately i'm sorry sir you're fine go  as fast as i can he picks up on john's  need for assistance what was the total  again 12 33 12 33 i just can't seem to  remember  want me to help you  yeah i need a hand thank you for your  help he steps right in and gets to work  but when lynn questions his motives why  are you helping him  he hits her with the silent treatment  really don't you have better things to  do sir  for the woman in the back of the line  we need two more dollars she has no  problem giving her two cents there sugar  ma'am why are you giving him money  because i have a chicken why are you  helping this old man god helps me every  day right right you need to keep your  opinion to yourself you're a worker here  he's a customer